こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん会議とかミーティングと勉強とかするときってメモを
取ると思うんですよ
とってますとってませんメモ取ってる奴はクズだ
そんなことないですけどそんなことないんですけども木刀も書かないと覚えないこと
あるんで勉強とかかなりのと書く方なんですけどもそのかいた後の目ボウを食べると人
はどういう反応するんですっ
って自分でもなきゃいんだろうと思うんですけども食べれるでもあるんですよねか
ミーハー
ここ開け煽ると音がなおなターンの桜なんかをの大友消すオーナー日が過ぎたおら髪を
タオルである learn
の味はおらん狂らをなる
ほら日本語で関係日本もでだけ日本語が英語かどっちかにしてくれこれが一番読み
づらい
食べれそうです本当に食べる文化もちょっとわかんないんですけど多分
食べれそうなんですよこちらが問題のメモ用紙
怪しい怪しい怪し
クエンはこれは食えんわおめっちゃっとに神は何な香りです2の神ですよこれ食べれ
たら大したもんに本当によってなんかそれっぽい女も済みしたんでこんなメモ用紙2枚
こと忍ばせておきましょうってサイズと鳥切ないおめっ
ちゃんまあこれはがれーんでしょたぶん何ないが感度区間特急
これぞ前こうやって出てきても家でやっぱで光沢とかはつ選んで実家に見られると
バレるともですのパッっと出てきてもそんなわかんないと思うんですよねじゃあこれな
んですけどそしてこちらがペンですこんなもん
んだね衝撃だよフードペンって矢部ね食用10パワーガードだね
この食用インクなので食品への文字が書けます
い
くってみますねなんて人に回避するんですけど貝塚でなんかノートトロフィーしますと
こうやっていっ
早いはい高は姉あーこれクーッ結構がっつり書いてますけどこれを
突然
ああああああ
ああああああああ
おっ
ああ
ちょっとる前俺の好きな子だこれよかった
ローザンてちゃんと食べれて体いうドッキリにやっていこうと思いますなに簡単です
会議所まとめナイロン適度なこと言ってる時に僕は今でメモしてその後にこうやってペ
リってるパパてたけど僕動いた時の周りの反応を見ていきたいと思いますがマジで
フレーズで所有地だと思いますよさすがにメモした紙を食べると
追われてないと思うので人間は果たしてどういう顔になるどうかを見ていたいと思い
ます監視カメラとけばれないように気を付けますでは
大一番ん
ていた
th
ん
ましょうございます
たまにはねぇ
でもっ
まだバブルちょっと記事見ていきましょうパックだけ
組てくる
思っていた
いいえいます
ことでいうパン作りを作る以外ならノートを買うとしても以前からちょっと
回転すること広報マン事はありません
ん
じゃシンプルに入った
win さんの米田を募集する
book
東京行くことが理由
ストックネタみたいなザルですけど通行を何時だろう
ん
向こうで待ってとりあえずはちょっとダメだという時間に一緒に撮り私んだろうからと
善司氏が入ってるらしいよ
[音楽]
はぁ
うん
ただのババア秋葉原秋葉のうちかそうな頃ちょっと無理に浅草
田舎シェーパーその後でありますねし5カ所います
[音楽]
植物で撮ってみたはい
一つかよくねー
出だし多いですよいいきれいでしがも考えれば燃えるゴミだよああ
いやーなぜ
[音楽]
マーヤー時間寝るったのはぁ
えっなんで rarejob to do
nar
山よどれでしょうねぇ a
on
[音楽]
ドッキリでしたぁー
ブーバーし
あっはぁし